people were a little bit surprised when
Amy revealed on her Netflix special that
he was diagnosed with autism spectrum
disorder but Amy's explaining why she
did it we both wanted to talk about it
because it's been totally positive I
think a lot of people resist getting
diagnosed and even some of their
children because of the stigma that
comes along with it all the
characteristics that make it clear that
he's on the spectrum are all of the
reasons that I fell madly in love with
him the tools that we've been given have
made his life so much better in our
marriage and our life more manageable
and so I just wanted to you know
encourage people to not be afraid of
that stigma Amy says husband of just
over a year Chris Fisher was totally on
board with going public with his
diagnosis she made the revelation during
her new Netflix stand-up special growing
he's an amazing guy I don't want to make
it sound like like I'm so nice that I
married someone with autism like yeah
like I loved I fell in love with him Amy
says one of Chris's characteristics is
that he can't tell alive well that
sounds great in theory she told Seth
Meyers it can be both a blessing and a
curse
you need your partner to be like yeah we
do have to get home know we've know he's
here and I came out and I was right
before cuz I changed outfits I'm like
does this look okay and he was like well
it's too late
he's right though it was too late
[Music]